gefahr durch atomwaffen das
worst-case-szenario
schätzungen des
friedensforschungsinstituts sipri zeigen
circa 13.000 nuklearwaffen gibt es
weltweit mit abstand am meisten
atomwaffen gibt es in russland gefolgt
von den usa auf platz drei china
auch frankreich und das vereinigte
königreich besitzen atomwaffen außerdem
pakistan indien israel und nordkorea
doch atomwaffe ist nicht gleich
atomwaffe unterschieden wird zwischen
strategischen und taktischen
nuklearwaffen
strategische atomwaffen können mehr als
5500 kilometer distanz zurücklegen etwa
von moskau nach washington und ganze
regionen zerstören
kleinere taktische atomwaffen können
dagegen weniger weit fliegen und haben
eine geringere sprengkraft sie können
objekte gezielter angreifen wie diese
waffen aktiviert werden hängt von der
jeweiligen atommacht ab in russland gibt
es zum beispiel drei atom koffer
ausgestattet mit einem
kommunikationssystem und codes den
ersten koffer besitzt präsident putin
den zweiten der russische
verteidigungsminister sergej schoigu der
als guter freund putins gilt der dritte
ist beim chef des generalstabs der
russischen streitkräfte valérie
gerasimov um atomwaffen zu aktivieren
wurden bis anfang der 90er alle drei
koffer benötigt aktuell geht man davon
aus dass nur noch zwei gebraucht werden
zuletzt waren die koffer nicht aktiv
russland befand sich in stufe eins
seines atom stufenplans doch am sonntag
hat wladimir putin befohlen die
atomstreitkräfte in erhöhte
alarmbereitschaft zu versetzen damit
tritt stufe zwei in kraft truppen sind
in dauerhafter bereitschaft in stufe
drei militärischer gefahr werden die
waffen scharf gemacht stufe 4 bedeutet
tatsächlichen krieg mit nuklearwaffen
in den usa gibt es ebenfalls drei atom
koffern die befehlsgewalt liegt bei
präsident joe biden als er stirbt ist
ein zweiter bei vizepräsident in kanada
harris und einer beim sogenannten
designierten überlebenden falls beide
sterben mit codes identifiziert sich der
präsident um die waffen auszulösen
us atomwaffen sind auch in deutschland
gelagert auf dem luftwaffenstützpunkt
büchel in der eifel sollen etwa 15 bis
20 us-atombomben liegen
dahinter steckt das nato konzept der
nuklearen teilhabe
dabei werden an der übung und planung
von us atomwaffen einsetzen auch
mitgliedsstaaten ohne eigene
nuklearwaffen einbezogen die absolute
kontrolle liegt allerdings weiter bei
den usa zuletzt versicherte joe biden
die amerikaner müssten sich keine sorgen
um einen atomkrieg machen eine längst
vergessene angst die jetzt durch den
russischen präsidenten wieder geschürt
wird
und in bonn begrüße ich jetzt joachim
weber sicherheitsexperte beim think tank
der uni bonn
prof
müssen wir uns wirklich fürchten dass
wladimir putin bis zum äußersten geht
und die atombombe gezündet
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt müssen wir das
sicherlich nicht befürchten was bisher
geschehen ist ist dass die russen einen
level in der bereitschaft ihrer
strategischen nokias kräfte herr
aufgegangen sind das ist ja bei den
russen ein vier stufen systemen bei den
amerikanern in fünf stufen system aber
dieses herausgehen einen level
beschreibt sozusagen nur das
tatsächliche ausmaß der krise und das
ausmaß der gefahr aber das ist noch weit
entfernt davon wirklich bedrohlich zu
werden es ist eine drohgebärde
was ist denn für sie das gefährlichste
an der lage im moment
naja das gefährlichste an der lage
glaube ich liegt darin dass für drohen
auf eine abschüssige bahn zu geraten und
wir verstehen alle weil wir ja auch alle
mit der ukraine fühlen sie es opfer
eines eines brutalen angriffs krieges
wir verstehen alle und wollen alle die
ukraine unterstützen und das ist auch
richtig und gut dass wir das tun wir tun
das politisch wir tun das wirtschaftlich
wir tun das auch zunehmend militärisch
letzteres muss uns auch beginn ein
bisschen sorgen zu machen es ist richtig
dass wir in ukraine an defensiv waffen
zur verteidigung liefern die
panzerfäuste die stinger
flugabwehrraketen die durchaus ein
kleines stück heizung game changer
werden könnten aber wir müssen auch
sehen dass wir nicht in eine situation
hinein geraten in der der westen eu nato
anfängt die die logistik sozusagen der
kriegführenden ukrainischen armee zu
übernehmen dann drohen wir kriegspartei
zu werden und dann sind die eskalation
risiken höher sie werden dann bedeutend
höher als sie möglicherweise bisher
gewesen sind heute sprach ja moskauer
davon dass die ukraine angeblich selbst
versuche atomwaffen zu bekommen wie
glaubhaft ist das denn
das halte ich für wenig glaubhaft auch
in keiner weise für nachvollziehbar
erscheint mir eher einen ein element der
psychologischen kriegsführung zu sein
was deutlich machen soll nach außen die
ukraine ist schlimm die ukraine bedroht
russland ist stellt die verhältnisse auf
den kopf die ukraine bedroht wirklich
das mächtige russland nicht wir sehen
jeden tag wie russische streitkräfte in
der ukraine agieren schießen und bomben
es gibt aber keine ukrainischen
streitkräfte die in russland schießen
oder bomben es würde auch überhaupt
keinen sinn machen aus ukrainischer
perspektive denn selbst wenn sie eine
zwei atombomben sich verschaffen sollte
die kann sie doch überhaupt nicht
einsetzen in dem moment in dem sie in
irgendeiner weise damit gegen gegen
russland es ginge und die gegen die
russin einsetzen würde dann würde sie so
einen vernichtenden atomaren gegenschlag
der russen erleben also so verrückt kann
und wird niemand sein